as a sound to get serious we need to
talk about the tragic power of this
podcast what do you mean well on a
summer s'mores episode from this summer
I mentioned a specific dessert that I
like to enjoy with some bourbon from a
place called Little Flower in Pasadena I
don't want to name the dessert and I'll
tell you why my wife went in there this
weekend we had this whole weekend
planned out she was going to pick up
this dessert
I'm gonna come home drink some Bourbon
and watch 1990s flatliners okay she went
there and they said sorry we're out did
you hear about it on the Conan podcast
really I'm not imitating anyone there
they're actually wonderful but they had
a little bit of attitude kind of and my
wife said actually that was my husband
that said that
about this and people have been coming
in name checking Conan and
selling out they've been selling out
this dessert that I love it's kind of
like Midas with the Golden Touch you
wish that everything you could touch
would turn into gold but then this power
becomes a curse yes uh you mentioned
this honeycomb dessert that you really
love that's sold in this little shop
that only you would find and
um
because it was an organic little treat
that enraged me I thought we can't talk
about it but you already talked about it
on the podcast I know I did and he just
said it right now but I'll bleep it out
no you're not gonna bleep that out it's
gonna people need to hear about this
wonderful dessert you like and if it
means that you never get to have it
again at least you've shared it with the
rest of humanity here's what needs that
no no you shared it with you shared it
with the rest of the world but let me
see you've had enough of you've stuffed
your face with enough of that oh please
stop honeycomb Honeycombs please stop
honeycomb stop
go in and buy the ginger molasses
cookies those are delicious if you see a
bag of milk chocolate covered honeycomb
if there's more than one take one but
always leave one because I am seconds
from coming in there and getting that's
ridiculous I I don't agree with this at
all this seems cruel and barbaric
you enjoy a dessert it really means a
lot to you you've had plenty of
enjoyment in your life some would argue
more than you deserve now it's time but
now it's time for you to share this
trait with other people but instead
you're sniping and and and whining I'm
taking my others others now are getting
a chance to enjoy this wonderful treat
packed with antioxidants and you are
bitching I think chocolate is no I think
yeah
dark chocolate yeah dark chocolate is
but milk chocolate this is covered in
milk chocolate Yes sounds delicious
everyone should get some honeycomb
covered in dark chocolate honeycomb just
leave honeycomb bag just if there's ever
one left don't take it that's all I'm
saying that's ridiculous no why should
you have more of it why I'm not asking
for more I'm just asking for some how
about this how about I make you some no
it would be that hard to go out and find
some honeycomb and and and melted milk
chocolate I can make that I can scrape
some M M's
my people at Little Flower they do the
best work there oh now you're buttering
them up because they're mad at you I bet
you're doing it I get it maybe then I
can just put more aside for me at any
given time that's can I ask you a
question yeah are they really irritated
do you think are the customers irritated
that they can't get it anymore maybe no
I don't know Little Flower is not
irritated they they are wonderful yeah
they just seem like really good people
they are
and they'd be even better if they kept
one off to the side well first of all
that's for you to go in and say hi I'm
Matt Gourley and when they're done
[ __ ] the floor
um because you're such a urban legend
um
then uh you should try their slash or
lose though I've had a slash Aloo trust
me
um but then uh why can't you help me
this one time why can't you use your
power what's the help that you need
right now I want him to convince them
and be on my side and you as well I'm
sorry I just wasn't sure what the game
plan was just leave one bag or something
because I've met your beautiful wife and
your beautiful daughter you have that
lovely house everything's just so
everything's just going your way so
perfectly and then you have this little
treat and what is it it can't be a
little treat like Twizzlers or some
other candy that everyone else likes no
It's gotta be from a little It's gotta
be from a little shop a shop called
Little Flower oh do you have the
honeycomb that's been caressed in milk
chocolate good I'll put it in my little
silk
pouch and they'll pull the string oh
it's so tight and now I'll tie it to my
little belts that I got as a Boy Scout
ah there nicely tied now I'll skip home
honey I'm home I love you I love you too
hello daughter
so can I ask you a quick favor yeah
what's Conan drinking right now he's
drinking hint water hint water hint
water I just drink it it's free we get
cases of this stuff no you can't justify
that you're drinking hint water I'm
drinking whatever's here put a bottle of
gin here and open the cap and I'll drink
it I'll drink whatever's here I don't go
hunting for some little feet
I bet there's a little bell on the door
jingle jingle jingle like a storehouse
someone comes out
[Applause]
well I'm fine Mrs Penny Whistle
oh come on how can we help you today
Matt well I was wondering if I could get
some of my little honeycomb covered in
chocolate
oh look it's all gone Matt we've sold
out sold out God damn it pretty whistle
give me some give me some now what do
you have there I have a gun
put that away You're Gonna cough up more
I'll kill everyone here
and that's broken
yes her name Mrs Penny Whistle
is there a little bell jingle jingle you
know what I'm gonna make some I'm gonna
get something I want your goddamn [ __ ]
recipe honey come I want My Little
Flower silk bag drawstring Penny Whistle
treat and I want it now we'll get it for
you trust me I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna intervene I will get you more of
this sweet little treat I promise from
Little thought it'll be from a store
you're just gonna give me like a half
chewed bit of Honey nope
I'm going to buy some candy that's sort
of like this but sold by a massive
retailer that's
what I just don't eat my eat my sugar
anymore so I want this okay
God damn it I'll get you something that
has honey and chocolate bits in it
that's sold by a massive chain you gotta
find something that Conan really likes
that's very particular you got to
mention it on this podcast and then
it'll be sold out then you'll feel what
he's feeling right now yeah you'll be a
little bit more empathetic I know what
if I told people about this like Fancy
Sushi place this shishi sushi place you
go to that you don't want everyone to
know about yeah I go to a sushi place
that everyone goes to it's a chain no
not that one the one you go to with Dana
Carvey too I think you know that's Dana
carvey's place that's it there's nothing
I do first of all I'm a man of the
people I don't go to those special
little places okay I get calls all the
time from these stores that you go to
where you find something you really like
and then you buy it okay not true no it
is true I'm your assistant and that
happened can you you don't have to name
the place
not much right now listen my listen my
point is you're going to get this candy
I'm going to take care of it for you it
may not be from Little Flower I'm not
interested it may not be but it'll be
something that I find that contains some
of those elements that's disgusting yeah
so anyway let's just take care of that
all right A Little Flower I love you
help me out Mrs Penny Whistle we're
sorry for the intrusion